[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday March
22nd I just mixed a misprinted business
card utilization idea with putting stuff
on my head now I have to do is put a
misprinted business card in my pants and
then put my pants on my head
mm-hmm so I haven't forgot what I'm
gonna talk about today well first I have
to show you how I made this misprinted
business card utilization idea and
second I think I'm going to talk about
the continuation of the Brotherhood 2.0
book club
a very long time ago a commenter
suggested that I make a cube out of my
misprinted business card and I thought
he was kind of crazy but then I realized
all I needed was a little magic okay
actually he sent me to a tutorial you
need six business cards you actually
will eventually need 12 but start with
six they'll be the exact same size which
is fine for me because I'll mine are the
same size then you take one and you bend
it over the other you end up with these
little cups you have to combine them
using a lot of manual dexterity them
together this is half the cube this is
when I get starts take really hard this
on camera because you have to hold
everything while you're doing it one
more piece and the cube will be done wah
suddenly a surprisingly sturdy cube now
this is kind of ugly what the tutorial
advises is that you use these flappy
things here and here and you use other
little cups that you've made you slide
them into your floppy things like so
your face now becomes a flat pretty face
instead of these tabby ugly faces so now
you just do that six times and you've
got this this is a beautiful little eco
geek cube that I've used now
in my intros to my ego geek videos which
you will soon be able to see on eco geek
dot org now everyone knows that I had to
read we wish to inform you that tomorrow
we will be killed with our families you
didn't have to read anything because the
book I made you read was your book that
you were writing because you needed to
finish your book because you were past
your deadline plus all the people who
watch Brotherhood 2.0 or John Green fans
and I think they would all hate me if I
stood between you and finishing your
book so I've decided that you should
read world-changing a users guide to the
21st century yes it is this big yes I am
kidding I considered asking you to read
The God Delusion
but I think maybe that would be a little
bit too inflammatory so instead I'm
asking you to read Bill McKibben's new
book deep economy because I run eco geek
I'm getting a free copy of deep economy
and I will be reading it too because I'm
probably going to be interviewing the
author for my website and it'd be good
to know what the books about
first and I'd like to talk about it with
you if possible before the interview
thank you to everyone who's taken my
plea to put stuff on your head so
seriously I really do believe that this
is at least in part an opportunity to
decrease worldsuck
I took like a Trojan I hope you all
won't think I'm selfish when I say this
I mean it's great to see John with dumb
stuff on his head and I do like putting
stuff on my own head but I kind of want
to see stuff on your head so maybe we
could set something up where people get
send us pictures of stuff on their heads
and videos and videos of stuff on their
heads and people doing stuff while stuff
is on their heads yes yes I think this
is a good idea anyhow I'll see you
tomorrow